Our disgusting tale of anomalous nastiness
begins in the humble town of Beckley, West
Virginia, back in the 1990s.
It was 10 AM on a hot day in early August,
as Oscar Duhigg was wending his way through
the wooded roads and back streets of town.
He isn’t the villain of our story, he’s
just a man doing his very unglamorous job:
Cleaning up roadkill for the local government.
Plenty of woodland critters met their ends
against the wheels and bumpers of careless
drivers, and it was thanks to the tireless
work of people like Oscar Duhigg that the
fine roads of rural America aren’t piled
high with carcasses.
Of course, Oscar was used to seeing some unpleasant
things on the job, but nothing like this.
When he began pulling over to the side of
a lonely street to pick up a dead deer, he
was shocked to see a sudden flash of stark
white illuminated by his headlights.
It was a naked, human woman, crouched over
the deer carcass.
She was sucking at the exposed red flesh on
the deer’s flank, as though feeding off
of it.
Flies circled around her in the hot summer
air.
The smell emerging from the deer carcass was
unspeakable, but the woman didn’t even seem
to care.
She just fed away, with a crazed look in her
eye.
And even more disturbing was the fact that
he recognized her: It was Mrs. Faber, a local
eccentric who lived with her husband on a
farm just outside of town.
Or at least, she had.
You see, Oscar Duhigg had never met Mrs. Faber
in person before - he only recognized her
from the missing person fliers posted around
town.
He pulled out his cell phone to call the authorities
when suddenly, Mrs. Faber was startled by
something and fled into the woods.
This would be the first of many encounters
reported by townsfolk concerning Mrs. Faber
- or more specifically, the anomalous species
that once was Mrs. Faber, and is now designated
SCP-726.
Mrs. Faber practically became a local cryptid,
similar to that of sasquatch or the Loch Ness
Monster with sightings of her in the woods
and around town frequently being reported
by the locals.
Of course, Mr. Faber was beside himself about
this whole situation.
What was happening to his beloved wife?
People assumed a psychotic break or some kind
of sudden onset of acute dementia.
She had to be apprehended and brought in for
her own good before she caused harm to herself
or others.
And on August 16th, she was finally found
and captured.
Mrs. Faber was found in the dumpster of a
local diner with a large dog.
After being subdued, she was sent to a nearby
hospital.
Her condition had seemingly advanced to the
point where she was no longer even capable
of speech.
However, if it had ended there, the SCP Foundation
wouldn’t have been called in.
It would have just been a sad local story
of a woman who became very unwell.
But that was only the beginning to the true
strangeness behind SCP-726.
Random livestock, like cows and pigs, were
found across the town, behaving incredibly
bizarre - exhibiting actions and traits uncommon
of their respective species.
And the most shocking of all was that the
sightings of Mrs. Faber around town still
didn’t stop, despite her being actively
held by a local hospital.
Naturally, that’s when the SCP Foundation
decided to take control of the situation.
They dispatched field agents to properly investigate
and figure out what was going on in Beckley,
West Virginia.
That’s when they discovered a peculiar commonality:
Maggots.
You see, the behavior exhibited by the strange
animals and by Mrs. Faber was not consistent
with their own species, but they were incredibly
consistent with the behaviors of the common
botfly - a particularly unpleasant form of
fly that sometimes lays its eggs in the bodies
of still-living animals.
The anomalously affected entities exhibited
insectoid movements, an affinity for rotting
meat, and even strange shifting of the back
muscles, suggesting the gesture of flapping
wings that weren’t there.
But what was going on here?
Was this mind control, or something more insidious?
As it turned out, the key to unlocking this
mystery was in the dumpster that Mrs. Faber
was found in.
An entire pig was found inside the dumpster,
exhibiting the same strange behaviors as the
other anomalous animals.
But not long before it was transformed into
a pig, it was simply a half-eaten hot dog
thrown to waste in the garbage.
This miraculous transformation came courtesy
of SCP-726, now also known as the Reconstructive
Maggots.
Much like regular maggots, these creatures
are attracted to decaying flesh and will multiply
and consume dead bodies or rotten food rapidly.
However, the truly strange thing is what happens
afterward.
The maggots will expel purified waste matter,
which then reconstitutes back into a kind
of living, exact clone of the entity it once
was.
Well, “exact” in a physical sense.
In a psychological sense, these clones are
exactly like a mature botfly.
The maggots that reconstitute these bodies
die off almost immediately, but whenever two
of these clones mate - with reproductive behavior
often being inspired by the presence of carcasses
or spoilt meat - they produce more eggs, which
in turn release SCP-726 maggots and begin
the cycle all over again.
And fascinatingly, these maggots can reconstitute
an entire clone from even a portion of the
original creature.
Which begs the question: Why were there seemingly
multiple Mrs. Fabers sighted in and around
the town of Beckley, West Virginia?
Upon further investigation into Mrs. Faber
and her husband, a terrible secret came to
light: Mr. Faber had murdered his wife in
a fit of rage and cut up her body, before
burying the pieces around the grounds of his
home.
Unbeknownst to him, an infestation of SCP-726
maggots across the property ate each piece
and reconstituted them into individual, fly-brained
clones of the original.
Mr. Faber was later arrested for the murder,
and multiple people in the town of Beckley
were given amnestic treatment to forget the
strange and frightening things they’d seen.
But for the Foundation, the strange and frightening
things were only just beginning.
An unnamed doctor with the SCP Foundation
decided to conduct a series of utterly repulsive
experiments on SCP-726, opening the log with
the fateful words, “I've decided to begin
by testing the limits of repeated replication.
A single SCP-726 egg will be introduced per
sample.
Due to their rapid multiplication, maggot
volume does not affect their speed of operation,
only the size of the organism to be reconstructed.”
The first subject was a recently deceased
Norwegian rat, cut in half lengthwise.
When the SCP-726 eggs were introduced, the
two halves were rapidly constituted into a
pair of living rats with mirrored fur patterns.
Both of these rats were then ground into a
fine paste, and mixed, wondering if SCP-726
would create a hybrid.
They did not, instead separating the mix into
two piles and once again creating two rats,
nearly identical to the ones before - except
for one of them now having a red right eye.
The rat without the red right eye was processed
into a fine paste - get used to hearing that
phrase - before the introduction of more SCP-726
samples.
It reproduced a close approximation of the
rat it once was, aside from a slight limp
and blindness in both eyes.
The heart was then taken from this rat, and
upon the introduction of SCP-726 into the
heart, it was reconstituted without eyes or
any pigmentation.
A note also mentions that the creature squeaked
incessantly.
The heart from this rat was then taken and
cut in half before SCP-726 was introduced.
The result was a pair of even more severely
messed-up, eyeless rats.
One could only walk in tight circles, and
the other immediately attacked the first rat.
The doctor noted that both physiology and
insect behavior seems to degrade with repeated
reconstitutions of the same genetic material.
Next, a scrap of flesh was taken from the
hairless rat.
The creature that reconstituted from this
was hairless, eyeless, and limbless, and didn’t
successfully survive for long.
A liver was found inside its braincase.
But because this particular researcher hadn’t
spit in the face of god enough for one day,
the tests continued.
The liver from the brainless rat was given
a dose of SCP-726, and the result was an eyeless,
legless, limbless creature with a long, wormlike
midsection, which quickly began to devour
its own posterior before dying of blood loss.
This dead rat was then put through three more
iterations of testing.
It first became a large, formless mass of
tissue, and then a long, slug-like creature
that takes in nutrients through its skin.
After this, no more changes were recorded,
as it had presumably reached peak performance.
The scientist decided to keep this creature
for long-term observation, naming it “Brundle”,
after the scientist in David Cronenberg’s
remake of “The Fly.”
At this point, the doctor began to conduct
tests that, mercifully, did not involve any
more rats.
Instead, the Foundation moved on to humans.
Dried flesh from a body that’s over 2000
years old was given to SCP-726, leading to
a full reconstitution of a middle-aged man
with the mind of a fly - opening doors to
potential practical forensic applications
of SCP-726.
Humans seem to experience a similar degree
of form degradation after multiple reconstitutions
from the same genetic material, but due to
humans being larger and more complex organisms,
the changes are often less pronounced - like
changes in eye color or fingerprints.
While the forensic use of SCP-726 is an open
door, clones produced by SCP-726 are worthless
for both medical and food purposes.
During one experiment, SCP-726 was used to
replace a missing chunk of a wounded D-Class’
leg.
This appeared to be successful at first, until
the D-Class later experienced a rapid mental
devolution into a fly-like state, just like
the other victims of SCP-726.
The D-Class was terminated and the test was
recorded as a failure.
It’s believed that a similar thing would
happen if organ transplants were taken out
of SCP-726 clones and given to non-anomalous
donors.
SCP-726 was used to clone several livestock
animals, such as cows and pigs.
Food items like steaks were rendered from
these animals, cooked, and given to D-Classes.
Much like the transplants, this led to a similar
state of devolution for those who ate the
infected meat.
Even when the meat was thoroughly disinfected
and processed, the anomalous effects remained.
So no, SCP-726 won’t be ending world hunger
any time soon.
Though if it gave us all the minds of flies
through tainted meat, it may at least end
all global warfare, seeing as flies don’t
have the mental capacity to create or wield
weapons.
At this point, it seemed that the researcher
was just curious, and felt like trying some
other random experiments, just for the heck
of it.
Like getting SCP-726 to reconstitute a non-anomalous
botfly, leading to the clone simply being
an unusually large botfly, which died shortly
thereafter.
Or testing a burger patty from a local independent
drive-through restaurant, that reconstituted
into two different cows and one large rat.
Yummy!
But the most horrifying result of all came
when they tested SCP-726 on what was supposedly
a vegan burger made entirely out of artificial
meat and plant matter.
The resulting creatures were so unimaginably
horrifying, they literally cannot be described.
Even hardened SCP Foundation researchers were
driven to scream and vomit at the mere sight
of them.
One of these creatures was killed and ground
into a fine paste before SCP-726 was introduced
again.
Somehow, this resulted in something even worse,
a truly horrifying, unkillable entity on par
with SCP-682.
Even when they liquefied the beast, it kept
attacking.
They could only stop it by freezing it and
keeping it on ice.
Testing into SCP-726 was suspended shortly
afterward.
Aaahhh - maggots, botflies and rat paste - how
lovely.
If you were eating during any of this, well,
you only have yourself to blame.
Now go check out “SCP-2852 Sadistic Madman
Party Crasher | Cousin Johnny” and “SCP-5049
- The Skin Salesman - Demon Dan's Discount
Homunculus Depot” for terrifying tales of
anomalous body horror!